have you ever woken up in the middle of
the night in a panic wondering how to
extract a polygonal mesh of an ISO
surface from a three-dimensional
discrete scalar field yeah I didn't
think so but back in ' 87 two
programmers at General Electric did they
created and patented the marching cubes
algorithm an algorithm that is likely
saved countless lives by allowing
doctors to visualize data from CT and
MRI scans whenever you instruct a
machine to solve a problem with code
you're creating an algorithm a procedure
for rearranging ones and zeros that can
make animals talk and vacuums walk most
algorithms belong in the dumpster but
some are fast some are beautiful and
some are so weird they're
indistinguishable from Magic today we'll
look at 10 of the most interesting
algorithms ever engineered and how
they're used to solve very interesting
problems in the real world first on the
list we have wave function collapse one
of the weirdest things in all of science
is the double slit experiment where
particles behave like a wave when you're
not looking but when you look they
suddenly collapse down to a particle it
seems counterintuitive but it makes
total sense when you realize we're
living in a simulation and the universe
wrote this algorithm to cut down on its
AWS bill it's an interesting concept to
think about philosophically but the
general idea behind wave function
collapse can also be implemented
programmatically imagine we have a map
for a video game but what if this is a
sidescrolling game that can go on for
eternity we can't just make a bigger map
we need an algorithm to procedurally
generate it on the Fly what's so weird
is that we can take this initial map and
think of it as being in the initial
super position of all possibilities it's
the wave function then upon observation
it collapses into a particle or in other
words it selects a Rand a map tile but
follows a consistent set of rules like
in this case making sure that the roads
are always connected providing a random
yet cohesive result and doesn't rely on
any sort of modern generative AI
speaking of which AI is weird as hell
diffusion is a machine learning
algorithm originally developed at open
Ai and is the magic behind image
generators like Dolly and stable
diffusion but the concept of diffusion
actually comes from thermodynamics where
particles spread from areas of higher
concentration to lower concentration in
artificial intelligence the process is r
reversed the algorithm starts by
generating random noise which would be
like high entropy in thermodynamics and
gradually refines it to a structured
image which would be lower entropy but
first you'll need to train a model that
can do this well the diffusion algorithm
Works in two phases in the forward phase
it gradually adds noise to an image step
by step until it becomes completely
random in the second phase the algorithm
reverses this process reconstructing it
back into a coherent image when the
algorithm runs over millions of labeled
images we get a collection of Weights
that can be used to generate new images
out of thin air allowing us to build an
infinite Army of only fans models it's
highly compute intensive but also works
well on audio and the next Frontier is
diffusion for video generation but now
let's talk about simulated analing one
frustrating thing about programming is
that for many problems there's not just
one solution but many solutions like an
Amazon warehouse has many different ways
to organize its inventory but some ways
are more efficient than others an neine
is a word that comes from metery where
metals are heated up and cooled down
over and over again to to remove defects
the same idea is used in optimization
algorithms to find the best answer in a
CA of good answers imagine trying to
find the highest point in a mountain
range full of Peaks and valleys a simple
Hill Climb algorithm won't work because
there are many local Peaks initially the
temperature starts High allowing the
algorithm to explore freely as time goes
on though the temperature is lowered
which decreases the probability of
accepting a worse solution the trade-off
here is exploration versus exploitation
but the reason I included this algorithm
is because it's also a good way for
beginners to learn how to code initially
you start out exploring all kinds of
different Technologies and Frameworks
then eventually you find one specific
area to exploit and specialize in but we
can't talk about algorithms without
talking about sorting and the most
ingenious sorting algorithm of all time
is without a doubt sleep sort the
majority of say sorting algorithms out
there use strategies like divide and
conquer to break up an array into
subarrays where it can be sorted more
efficiently however some random genius
on forchan found a better way but it's a
bit unconventional here's what the code
looks like in Bash it's incredibly
simple it Loops over the array and then
for each element it opens up a new
thread that sleeps for the amount of
time proportional to the value of its
element then finally after waking up it
prints that element it's genius because
it delegates the Sorting to the CPU
scheduler it's also incredibly dumb and
useless because it delegates sorting to
the CPU scheduler speaking of which you
might be familiar with another useless
sorting algorithm BOGO sort which tries
to sort an array by randomly guessing
over and over again it's like playing
the lottery but what if we apply the
same algorithm with Quant mechanics to
the Multiverse if we're to trust
Multiverse science we know that all
possible outcomes exist in separate
parallel universes that means as a
developer if you find yourself with an
unsorted array there's some other
parallel universe where it is sorted the
technology isn't quite there yet but if
we could randomly observe these other
universes to find the sworded array we
could then use a portal gun to travel to
that Universe which would make our lives
much easier although we would obviously
have to kill the version of oursel in
that universe but if it's a really large
array Quantum BOGO sort might be worth
it that's purely hypothetical but one of
the most practical and goed algorithms
of all time is RSA a public key crypto
system it's essential for digital
security allowing people on the internet
to lock their mailboxes and sign their
letters with a unique signature but it's
based on one simple mathematical reality
multiplying large numbers to find two
original large prime numbers is
extremely difficult and timec consuming
like it take your laptop 300 trillion
years to brew Force unless quantum
computers become a thing and we can
start leveraging Shores algorithm which
can solve the integer factorization
problem exponentially faster than any
classical algorithm Prime factoring is
pretty simple but how this algorithm
does it is where things get weird it
relies on Concepts like cubits
superposition and entanglement to
perform massive amounts of calculations
in parallel the algorithm is legit but
so far the biggest number ever factored
is
[Music]
21 even IBM state-of-the-art Q system
one fails when trying to factor the
number 35 however just recently the
Chinese factored this big ass number
with a quantum computer but it uses a
different algorithm that doesn't scale
very well for large numbers unlike
Shores algorithm everything is safe for
now but when someone figures out how to
make quantum computers work expect all
hell to break loose in the cyber
security world at the beginning of this
video I mentioned the marching cubes
algorithm but it deserves a closer look
so first we start with a 3D scalar field
which might represent data from an MRI
machine each point in the 3D space is
represented by a single number or scaler
the algorithm starts with a single point
then takes its eight neighboring
locations to form an imaginary Cube but
treats the values as a bit in an 8bit
integer this results in 256 different
possibilities which point to a
pre-calculated array of polygons the
algorithm marches through each point to
create a 3D mesh that can be used in 3D
software and at the time this was really
cool because MRI machines produce slices
of data that can now be rendered in 3D
in modern times though we're often
dealing with distributed systems in the
cloud and that brings us to the
Byzantine generals problem imagine
you're a general in the Byzantine Army
you're camped around a city with a few
other generals with plans to attack
attack at the next morning but what if
one of the generals gets drunk and wakes
up to hung over to attack the entire
system could collapse computers have the
same problem sometimes they might fail
or be infiltrated by hackers and you
never know when or where that's going to
happen luckily algorithms like pbft are
designed to solve this they can keep a
distributed Network working properly
even if up to onethird of its nodes go
Haywire it works by having a node
broadcast a pre-prepare message to other
nodes indicating its Readiness to
execute some code that will change the
system the other nodes will respond back
an agreement then after a certain
threshold a consensus is formed once
there's a consensus the original node
sends back a commit message to all the
other nodes which can then all execute
the changes making the entire state of
the system consistent algorithms like
this are essential for blockchain
technology and things like distributed
Cloud databases what's really cool about
algorithms though is that they can also
reflect nature like Boyd's artificial
Life program it was created back in ' 86
and simulates the flocking behavior of
birds what's so cool about it is that it
demonstrates the emerging complexity or
beauty that we get out of just a few
simple rules in this case the birds have
three rules they steer to avoid crowding
they steer towards the average heading
of the flock and they steer towards the
center of mass of their local flock
mates the end result are these intricate
patterns that weren't programmed
directly but just emerge naturally but
finally that brings us to an old
algorithm that blew my mind just the
other day and inspired this video boy or
more string search it's weird because it
becomes faster and more efficient as the
string it's searching becomes bigger
that seems impossible but it makes sense
when you understand the algorithm it
scans text from right to left then has
two rules when it encounters a bad
character not found in the search
pattern it jumps past it based on an
estimation made in a pre-processed table
likewise if it finds a partial match
then a mismatch occurs it has a separate
pre-calculated table that maximizes the
number of characters it can safely skip
these rules are called horis STS which
are like functions that are not
guaranteed to be perfect but are far
more practical than looping over every
single character in this case the
algorithm gets faster with more text
because it's able to to skip a higher
proportion of characters and if you've
ever wondered why grep is so fast you
have this algorithm to thank